- one what's up everyone welcome thanks
for tuning in we are going to be talking
about Logan Paul and before we do there
has been a lot of sensationalist
clickbait t-type youtubing that's been
going on and even the mainstream media
and journalism has been the whole
business model is funded by advertising
and click baiting and all this kind of
stuff that is about the attention
economy and it's not actually about the
dissemination of quality information so
from now on I challenge us all to be
focused on the dissemination of quality
information first and foremost so now -
the title of this video about giving
Logan Paul a second chance
first of all let's all take a quick
moment to just chill and relax a little
bit take a breath and just remember our
humanity because everybody deserves a
second chance
nobody's perfect everyone messes up the
least we can do is extend an arm out and
say how can we help rehabilitate what's
going on how can we help make it better
because when we kick people and we
torture them psychologically and
emotionally it's really bad and it makes
things worse so let's reach out and give
people a second chance now who do I
think Logan is at his core I've been
keeping an eye on Logan for about the
last year or so and I actually think
Logan is mostly maverick I think he's
mostly an eccentric person he's a very
unusual person he behaves in very
free-thinking sort of unusual ways and
what does that mean it means that when
you see people you know sitting here in
this chair going like what how I'm
talking to you Logan might you know do
something like
you know he might jitter about or like
do something crazy for a second and you
know it's totally okay to throw people
off like that it's actually very okay
and very needed in our world the fact
that somebody can live a life where they
challenge the obedience and the
complacency of the mainstream culture is
actually very good for humans now
pending it has to be a non egregious
ways we can't be outstandingly out
shockingly horrifically going against
mainstream culture because there's a
reason why we do things like we don't
bring video cameras and and laugh at
people that have committed suicide and I
think I do truly think that there has
been some lesson learned and I think
that there is a second chance that's
being given out right now and I think
it's important to extend that second
chance and also to foster a culture
where it's totally ok to be eccentric be
unusual and and have behaviors that are
completely different than the mainstream
culture like right now right you didn't
expect me to do that but I did it and
it's again I'm just breaking the
mainstream flow of things so do things
that are unusual doing things that are
eccentric I think that that is more of
what who Logan is and what he's about
alright so if you guys noticed another
thing that happened is that this is
something very recent this was actually
just a couple days ago Logan went and
got an interview done by Casey Knights
that Casey I've also been following for
about a year very very well done on a
lot of his videography work and what he
talks about and stuff so imagine this
Logan chooses to not do an interview
with a mainstream media outlet this is a
brand new thing that's come about
society people are choosing content
creators are not only going into boxing
matches against each other but they're
choosing to do interviews with each
other rather than with
or fox or MSNBC or even and even a
magazine like The New Yorker New York
Times Washington Post whatever it's
active because there's no there's not as
much trust
we've lost our trust with a lot of the
mainstream media outlets and now we see
more and more people going to this raw
if you noticed Casey's video was raw
which means there were no cuts this was
completely raw and uncensored unfiltered
unedited just like the stream is right
now this is a direct stream of
consciousness you're getting at how it
is and there's no cuts butts coconuts
nothing this is completely straight raw
unedited raw uncut and I think a lot of
our culture is moving this way we see
Joe Rogan doing multi-hour conversations
on his show nowadays in their raw their
uncut completely so now consider this if
we're moving away from mainstream media
to things like YouTube to see an
interview be done live and I think we
also saw this with Kanye West and Sharma
Lane as well we saw that Kanye went and
did an interview that was completely
away from mainstream media private only
launched onto a youtube again the
super-private launched and a super
private venue and a super private
conversation that happened about very
sensitive subjects that could not be now
that might have had some cuts and
whatnot but again it could not be
manipulated in a way that was out of
their control okay so that's another
important point here now where are
things going in the future I think that
what's going on with the boxing match
against ksi I think this is a very new
thing that's going on it's about
creating a lot of hype between tribes
and I think that that actually has an
interesting negative part to it if you
guys watch the press conference with ksi
and Logan Paul this last one that
happened they were in London and KS ice
tribe was yelling like [ __ ] the Paul's
[ __ ] Logan Paul and [ __ ]
Jake Paul and stuff like that and I I
don't actually I don't actually think
that that the pinning tribes against
each other in this sense and then going
through this boxing match and like
seeing what happens from there the
boxing match itself is you know fine but
the way that things are I guess are
going are a little bit more tribal and a
little violent at times there is a lot
of it seems like and a lot of negative
energy that's coming from that with you
know the way that like Louis dad was
treated and stuff like that and anyway
just to just to be just to be completely
clear here this is also just not the
best use in my opinion of their time
money fame resources I think that if
they devoted these things ksi and Logan
and Jake and all these people if if
large-scale content creators would work
on more humanitarian efforts with their
time maybe maybe who knows maybe I'm
wrong maybe they take the multi hundred
million dollar earnings that they'll
make off of this fight and it only
requires a couple million people from
around the world ten million people or
so to make it a you know a hundred
million dollar fight that that imagine
now taking that money and then investing
it into humanitarian causes so it's very
possible who knows that they take the
money from this fight and they go and
invest it into really good things of
humanity so that's ideally what I would
see potentially happen from this and
that's just a little bit of thoughts
from me to you I hope that we have more
eccentric things that occur in the world
I'm not sure if we're gonna have more
content creators going to boxing matches
or whatever is gonna happen in that
sense but I challenge us to have a more
of an overview perspective imagine
yourself on the moon looking at Earth
from the moon and you see the pale blue
dot and that that is the perspective
that we carry forward that it's not an
us-versus-them that we learn how to work
together let's figure that out as soon
as possible and let's do our best to
continue propagating a culture of being
eccentric and unusual in ways that are
non egregious
so let's figure that out cuz it's really
important to walk the offbeat path to be
the black sheep and to figure out how to
brew play around with the social fabric
in society in ways that are fun and
engaging and different but that again
don't cause massive drastic harm on to
people's lives as well so much love
thank you very much for tuning in to
some of these thoughts on Logan Paul as
well as just the idea of rehabilitation
and giving second chances is always very
important I've been given second chance
I'm sure you have too
so let's extend a hand out and help much
love everyone thank you very much
[Music]